cardinals and the bills you watched all
of the game i watched most of the game
this morning let's go back and yeah and
revisit that one 24 hours after the fact
do you feel any differently about the
execution or the defense of
what now is widely known as the hail
murray i no no i can't say that i feel a
whole lot different i don't you know i
think the one thing i still look at with
buffalo going hey a touchdown beats you
there and i
you got to defend the end zone at all
costs and to me they kind of tried to
have it a little bit both ways like you
know we're going to defend the end zone
but we don't want to let you have a 15
or 20 yard completion and that's to me
where they just overplayed their hand a
little bit and protecting the sideline
and protecting the middle of the field
where
i want to go it's 11 seconds if he
throws the ball in the middle of the
field and they get tackled the game is
over you need about 16 to 17 seconds to
throw completion in the middle of the
field and then spike the ball that's the
general thought in the nfl so you know
with that i still look at that and just
think buffalo
yeah didn't put enough people deep and
that caused a really the picture shows a
three on one right with hopkins on three
guys it was really a two on one
that's really poyer got there very late
because he was worried about somebody in
the middle of the field and that's where
i still go back to
in my experience with people and human
beings like deandre hopkins i didn't
play with a lot of wide receivers that
were like this but brandon marshall i
say we could throw him in that category
roy williams who i played with in
college top 10 pick had freakish ability
two on one jump balls with guys like
this deandre hopkins
it's it's not like oh they catch it one
out of every 10 times they're gonna
catch their share of them maybe not half
but they're gonna catch three or four of
them and i think that's where again i
just look at it not protecting the end
zone and having a guy like that now i
have a little extra attention on him is
probably where i i fought the bills a
little bit
peter king joined me yesterday for pft
pm and he had a different interpretation
of that play when he spoke to kyler
murray for football morning in america
one thing murray said to him is that as
he walked to the line of scrimmage
murray said the play that was called was
kind of in shambles now with murray
you it takes some effort to draw things
out of him he's a little bit naturally
shy which is perfectly fine i was at
that age but um
he thinks peter thinks that that the
play is designed the first option was
andy isabella number 11 on that crossing
route that you saw in the graphic we
just put up sure and that that's what
murray was supposed to do with the goal
of it getting out of bounds isabella's
fast completed get out of bounds and
then you've got a closer shot to the end
zone yeah than where you were and that
murray just decided i'm not gonna do
that instead of rolling left and there's
isabella crossing right to left instead
of that and you see there's two guys on
that who knows if he would have gotten
out of bounds murray just basically said
screw it i'm going to throw it deep to
deandre hopkins now that's inference
not an admission but you know whatever
it worked end result is it worked it did
what whatever whatever you did kyler
keep doing it because it worked yeah
well you know then i get the great
ability to get outside the pocket there
and make the play i mean that that's
still it's special there um but i think
hey ultimately the play was it bungled
by the buffalo yeah a little bit i don't
think it was egregious i'm not like oh
my gosh mcdermott and the bills are so
stupid how'd they do that i understand
it yeah we're talking about oh i would
have liked to have seen this but that's
easy to say sitting here on tuesday
morning
but
in the bigger picture of the football
game mike
man i was impressed with the cardinals i
think i'm i got to officially maybe jump
on with you and take them a little bit
more seriously
than
i
would have or was before this week and i
think there's there's two things one
hey their run game has become real
it really has you know you've heard me
complain a little bit about their past
game and it's not overly creative and i
felt like teams you i think you remember
me saying this i feel like teams have
got to beat on a little bit on their
schemes in the past game and you even
see in this game again it's
underwhelming throwing numbers let's
let's keep it in perspective if he
doesn't throw the hail mary he's going
to throw for 198 yards or 202 they're
not killing people with the pass game
but cliff kingsbury i give him a lot of
credit
he has changed himself a little bit into
hey i like to throw it 70 percent and
run it 30 percent to now it's all like
52 48 55 45 throw to run he's staying
patient with it i think it is because
he's realized wait i'm not going to be
able to drop back and throw it 45 times
a game and beat every team in football
there's going to be teams they're going
to be able to stop my passing game so
he's added this element to their
football team with drake and chase
edmonds and what it's also done is made
the kyler murray design runs way more
effective he had two touchdown runs not
even a finger was laid on him and that's
because of kingsbury's new attitude
towards the run game and i'll give him a
lot of credit for that that was that was
cool to see
here's kingsbury talking about the
running game that they have developed in
arizona i think you know they are a
great one-two punch and they they
complement each other
tremendously well um with all the
different skill sets that they have you
know chase
is a great change of pace great out of
the backfield catching it and you said
it allowed him to be fresh and really
bring a burst when he did get in the
game and i thought katie ran the ball
tough you know we'd like to have
that one back but i thought he finished
downhill and ran the ball tough and got
better as the game went on
it's a lot like what they have in
baltimore you've got two running backs
and the quarterback who
uh really is the most potent weapon and
yeah when when murray decides to go
he's just gone oh he's just he's gone
and and they kind of soften you up for
it like they don't do the designed run
all the time they kind of do it when you
least expect that even if you know what
was coming good luck good luck stopping
them no you're right and they you're
right they don't go to the well as much
as baltimore does on it but when they do
do it it's like they got the feel like
all right they're over playing our run
game or whatever
and now we're gonna call this with kyla
murray and you're right good luck i mean
it's every time he's kept the ball the
last two weeks on quarterback design
runs i mean there's a handful of them
where it's like this close to you go oh
my gosh that could have been
really scary for the defense right there
uh i love it and what they have as
compared that the baltimore doesn't
right and to where it can continue to be
more effective
is they have a more effective pass game
i mean cliff kingsbury's pass game is
certainly better than greg romans and
then they have a receiver like deandre
hopkins and fitz and isabella and
christian kirk where it's a respectable
all-around group so they can really put
you in some binds there and what i saw
in the game too mike a little more play
action pass i saw a few different
formations you know i think that all
bodes well for arizona really i was
impressed with arizona across the board
in the football game you know to me it's
they're growing as a team it's not just
a shotgun throw at every play
we've seen the last few weeks that their
offense is becoming a little more
versatile and their defense mike
you know
it wasn't killer the other day but they
matched up with some good weapons in
josh allen and made life tough on them
and i got to give vance joseph and the
cardinals defense a little credit in
this win as well
yeah there was uh
they're using the from time to time the
formation where there's no defensive
linemen
got their hand on the ground yeah so you
have no idea what the 11 guys are going
to do uh exactly right i mean this is
the you know we saw this member at the
end of the sunday night game with vance
joseph and russell wilson right where
it's like all these guys were at the
line of scrimmage that last interception
russell wilson threw right in overtime
because they had brought the blitz
brought the blitz and then everybody
dropped out and he thought oh they're
gonna bring the blitz again let me throw
it quick and it ended up being the
interception vance joseph has really
found a cool formula of messing with
people that way and you know the one
thing where i'm i know i dropped the
ball as an evaluator and we haven't
talked about this enough the cardinals
back seven is real i mean it's real yeah
they might not have chandler jones and a
big time d lyman but when you talk about
hicks and simmon and hassan riddick and
you know patrick peterson and byron
murphy and buddha baker and company you
start and even drake kirkpatrick you
start to go whoa there's a little talent
and speed in the back end there and
vance joseph has found a way to create
this chaotic defense where i don't know
who's who
and yeah it's five six linebackers in
the game and they can all cover and they
can all rush the passer and it was
really effective in not letting josh
allen make a lot of those you know
scrambling extending plays and doing
things like that and i give vance joseph
a lot of credit you talk about all the
time doing things that fit your
personnel right and i really look at him
and go he's adjusted a lot through the
year as figuring out his personnel and
what's worked best and uh they got
something going on that side of the ball
too
let's flip it over to the bill's offense
yeah
are they trying too hard
to to keep the ball in josh allen's
hands and let him do spectacular things
and justify the stephon diggs trade and
have the explosive offense instead of
developing a running game i know the
running game numbers were abysmal again
and josh allen the leading rusher was
with 38 yards zach moss had 20 and devin
singletary had 15. i i don't know if
it's something they're going to really
be able to fix this year
you know that they've they've kind of
hey no preseason football
you know everything like that the game
the year started off with them throwing
the ball and attacking and then because
their defense had issues in a lot of
games too they weren't able to ever
really start working a balanced game
plan you know really early on from the
year
it kind of became the josh allen show
and because the defense was bad they
never it always had to stay the josh
allen show so they've never been able to
really establish that and get that going
as part of their offense and i think
it's too late now i do it's a lot on
josh allen certainly but i don't think
that run game is going to get much
better it's a weird one to me mike
because it's a it's a it's a good old
line it's not bad we've seen them over
the last few years be able to run the
ball but i just think it's uh kind of
the mantra of this team this year
they've gotten away from it and they've
lost their physicality and nuance that
way to be successful
the uh the josh allen performance yeah
rushing
the throwing
the catch from isaiah mckenzie who was
the kyler murray scout team quarterback
for the week that you heard last week
rather excuse me for the for the bills
it's almost like what taysom hill could
be
you know yeah when you see that when you
look at these numbers i'm thinking yeah
is this some future glimpse of what
taysom hill possibly will become if they
ever do let him be a full-time
quarterback well i i mean
taysom hill has big arm and of course
has that size josh josh allen's special
you know
there's nobody that's gonna change my
mind on that at least right now until i
see some
more not special type things on the
football field but yeah a lot is on his
shoulders right now and his ability to
make plays and do things like that and
when you're one-dimensional and you play
a team like arizona with vance joseph
and oh all these linebackers and and
secondary guys who were interchangeable
and all of that
you know
the cardinals went all out on stopping
the pass and you know within stopping
the pass they caused the two turnovers
and that was because they're playing
some exotic coverages and doing things
like that on the first one that patrick
peterson got and he gets a little loose
with the ball at times but that's you
know a little like russell wilson it's
what to be expected to a degree you know
just everything is on them to make the
plays and execute the offense and we're
not gonna you know run the ball all that
effectively and our defense isn't great
so it's just always on you to go go go
go go
and we see every now and then they meet
some matchups where he just he can't
make magic happen all game long
let me spin it back to the hail mary and
just make two observations before we
transition to the patriots ravens game
first
the
color murray yellow cleats were beyond
awesome and i hope he wears them every
game that that's the most important
observation because you just see this
blur of yellow
secondly
and this is a point that peter king made
last night trenavius white was trying to
catch the ball instead of trying to
knock it down now he got knocked out of
the way by jordan poyer
but
you got to coach your guys in that
setting don't try what are you doing
trying to make the interception knock
knock the ball down knock it down knock
it down in the game
100
and i you do you think that's like
was mcdermott referring to him a little
bit in the post because he you know he
talked in the post-game conference he
kind of makes it like you know we
knocked the ball down in those instances
i felt like he was
referring to someone that he didn't
think was doing that i'm guessing it's
true davious white i am hey trenavius
white it's not been his best year this
year after an all-pro year last year i
can tell you he is not making all-pro
this year and that's a tough matchup for
him and that's again where we go back
into you defend the end zone at all
costs especially with a guy like that
he's a smaller corner and hopkins is a
bigger receiver with incredibly long
arms and gigantic hands and that's just
uh it was set up perfectly him for him
in that one-on-two situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports